And that is called future faking.
And those little changes that he does are called,
like, little bread crumbs that he will leave you,
or, like, hanging the carrot on the fishing pole.
They're all just manipulation tactics.
Um, and the whole like, oh,
I had a bad childhood,
I had a hard day,
I had this, I had that.
If you read the book why does he do that?
Inside the minds of angry and Controlling Men by Lundy Bancroft,
he goes into that.
That is just another manipulation tool.
You probably didn't have the best fucking childhood,
or you probably had some experiences in your life
that is stuck with you.
You don't use that to hurt people in your life,
especially the people closest to you.
These are just manipulation tactics that someone is using
to take the good in you
and use it for their gain
and to your detriment.
And you have to see it for what it is,
acknowledge it so that you can move on.
So I'm sending you so much love.
Just remember, you're not crazy.